[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir
richtig hübsche kate cupcakes und die
sind mit zitronengeschmack die zitronen
buttercreme habe ich euch bereits
gezeigt und jetzt geht's erst mal mit
der zubereitung für zitronen muffins
weiter wir benötigen bei 100 gramm mehl
160 g weiche butter 170 gramm zucker
eine prise salz ein halbe packung
backpulver das ist ein teelöffel zweier
dem saft einer zitrone und 50 milliliter
milch
[Musik]
er zeigt er geht auch richtig schnell
und einfach ihr mitfahrer erst die
butter den zucker und die prise salz in
der küchenmaschine circa fünf minuten
lang zu einer cremigen masse müssten
[Musik]
dafür am besten in ruhe haken wir
schneebesen eignet sich hier nicht so
gut ich wechsele den gerade auch aus und
dann wird ihr das weiter bis sie eine
cremige masse erhalten habe
[Musik]
anschließend werden die zwei eier mit
hinzugegeben und werden so lange
untergerührt wichtig das ganze
miteinander vermengt hat danach kommen
die trockenen zutaten mit hinzu also das
mehl backpulver die werden noch mal
gesiegt damit auch keine künsten dem
teig entstehen und das wird auch so
lange unterwegs bis sich alles
miteinander verbunden hat
[Musik]
guter letzt kommen die flüssigen zutaten
mit hinein also einmal der zitronensaft
und anschließend auch die milch und dann
wird das ganze nur noch einmal kurz
berührt und damit der teig auch schon
fertig denn was im teig teile ich mir
jetzt in meine zwölf förmchen auf jedes
förmchen bekommt väter anderthalb
esslöffel vom teig noch einmal ganz grob
streichen und dann kommen sie bei 200
grad ober und unterhitze für 20 minuten
in den backofen
lassen wir das ganze vollständig
auskühlen und solange geht es weiter mit
der deko nehme mir zuallererst violetten
von land und wolle ihn ob etwas becker
stärke aus jetzt kommen die hübschen
buchstaben ausstecher zum einsatz ich
verlinke ihr euch unten in die infobox
und generell alles was ich mit video
verwendet
und jetzt könnt ihr euch nach und nach
die buchstaben aus dessen bei diesem
sehr filigranen ausstellern bekommt er
sie am besten heraus wenn ihr das etwas
an trockenen lässt etwa zwei bis drei
minuten und dann klopft ihr einfach auf
die arbeitsfläche
[Musik]
das ganze habe ich dann sechsmal
wiederholt weil ich gerne die hälfte der
cup cakes mit dem schriftzug verzieren
wollte und was ihr auch noch braucht ist
der passende untergrund dafür habe ich
etwas weißen vom land ausgerollt und mit
diesen ausstellern ausgestochen
jetzt müssen die buchstaben nur noch mit
etwas wasser auf den weißen von land
untergrund geklebt werden und das tier
zu vollständig aus herten zweite fondant
oper ist so schnell und einfach gemacht
dafür nehmen wir uns einfach abweisen
von land und stechen mit einem runden
ausstecher zweimal aus einen halbmond
erhalten
dieser wird jetzt noch gold angemalt das
mache ich mit flüssiger
lebensmittelfarbe ihr müsst ihr auch
nicht extra anmischen die könnt ihr
sofort aus der tube verwenden wenn der
halbmond an gold ist dann könnt ihr das
nochmal austrocknen lassen und dann
geht's auch schon weiter
[Musik]
für diesen cache truppe habe ich mir
einen anderen ausstecher genommen auf
meinem bett und da gebe ich jetzt
einfach den mund drauf und noch etwas
besser drauf geben damit es auch schon
ein klebt und dann ist auch schon fertig
jetzt kommt meine lieblingsstelle mal
wieder zum einsatz die 1m von holten
damit spritzen wir die buttercreme
einfach auf und dann sind die muffins
auch schon fast fertig es fehlt nur noch
der von bumptop wie geben wir jetzt
einfach auf die muffins und die halten
wunderbar auf der butter kleben
bitte denkt daran dass vom land nur in
verbindung mit buttercreme oder ganz
drauf gesetzt werden kann also seine
vorstehen funktioniert hier leider nicht
die butter themen schmeckt aber
wunderbar und richtung slacker zitrone
für alle die jetzt auch richtig lust
haben die interception komplex
nachzumachen habe ich alles in die
infobox geschrieben und falls ihr denn
noch fragen haben deutet dann schreibst
du mir gerne in die kommentarfunktion
ich beantwortet euch so schnell wie
möglich wenn ihr keines meiner videos
mehr verpassen möchte dann lassen wir
doch gerne auch ein abo darf bis zum
nächsten mal auf nietzsches kitchen
[Musik]